simone biles is feeling the love i'm
excited
the 24 year old gymnast took to twitter
on wednesday to thank everyone for their
love and support
after withdrawing from the competitions
at the tokyo olympics
the outpouring of love and support i've
received has made me realize i'm more
than my accomplishments and gymnastics
which i never truly believed before
where we perform we're expected to win
which it can kind of get a lot at times
because we're so young with such
a big amount of pressure but i think we
handle it very well
on tuesday the athlete exited the
gymnastics team competition at the
summer olympics after the first rotation
then on wednesday morning it was
announced that she decided to withdraw
from the all-around competition as well
at the time the usa gymnastics team
tweeted quote
we wholeheartedly support simone's
decision and we applaud her bravery and
prioritizing her well-being
her courage shows yet again why she is a
role model for so many
everyone does strive to be the best and
we're such good friends that we're
rooting for each other no matter what
and we just want the best for each other
the statement also clarified that simone
will be quote
evaluated daily to determine whether or
not to participate in next week's
individual event finals where the
gymnastics superstar would be eligible
for more medals in the vault
uneven bars balance beam and floor
exercise
simone has a total of 30 olympic and
world championship medals
making her the most decorated american
gymnast
that is the ultimate goal and simone has
received a ton of love and support from
her fellow athletes and celebrities
praising her for putting her mental
health first
justin bieber posted a snap of the
olympian writing in part
quote nobody will ever understand the
pressures you face
i know we don't know each other but i'm
so proud of the decision to withdraw
michelle obama rhys witherspoon michael
phelps as well as simone's
boyfriend nfl pro jonathan owens also
expressed their support online
and simone's former dancing with the
stars pro sasha farber
told et he couldn't be more impressed
with simone
and her decision i feel so much
love for her she is such a hard worker
and i remember
um you know being in the gym with her
we had so much fun but there is just you
know this proves that she's human and
you know it's such a beautiful thing to
see i'm really thankful for that
the 24 year old standout athlete left
the competition floor during the team
finals on tuesday
after her first rotation on the vault
following her exit she spoke to the
today show
and gave a little insight into how she
was feeling physically i feel good i'm
in shape
emotionally that kind of varies on the
time in the moment you know
coming here to the olympics and being
the head
star of the olympics is not an easy feat
so we're just trying to take it one day
at a time and we'll see
she was ultimately replaced by alternate
jordan childs
and the team went on to win the silver
medal i'm super proud of these girls
that stepped up and did what they needed
to do and now we're
olympic silver medalist so it's
something that they'll cherish forever
after being awarded her silver medal
simone shared
this snap of her team on instagram
writing quote
olympic silver medalists i'm so proud of
these girls right here
you girls are incredibly brave and
talented i'll forever be inspired by
your determination to not give up and to
fight through adversity
they stepped up when i couldn't thanks
for being there for me and having my
back
forever love y'all
[Music]